it's 24 years since South Africa's
highest achievement in rugby was also
part of a turning point in the country's
history but now a team of players born
in the early days of Nelson Mandela's
rule is showing that the Springboks
victory at World Cup 1995 was not a
false dawn as they prepare for
Saturday's final against England
Mandela's presidency was just over a
year old when he handed the trophy to
Captain Francois Pienaar uniting a
deeply racially divided country behind
their team even so the squad was all
white apart from wing at Chester
Williams who died just two weeks before
World Cup 2019 began in Japan last month
now the team's first ever black captain
SIA Khaleesi is leading a lineup studded
with stars from the rural areas and the
townships coach Rossi Erasmus achieving
a step-up in performance alongside the
transformation of the squad's racial
balance I've had the privilege to see
the team evolve you know to get to know
so many guys in of color that I really
you know I've been excellent and in all
deserving of the places in the squad so
I think it's something that Rossi was
pretty honest you know right from the
onset that we need to get the balance
correct and we need to get a team that
really represents our country and that's
the hope you know we have achieved it a
South African win on Saturday could have
ripple effects beyond its borders
African rugby leaders believe the site
of a black African lifting the World Cup
would give the rest of the continent a
sporting icon it's been looking for your
basque on ethical is opportunity mildly
pull it Bellavia in Africa despite all
the talent we have there's not the same
opportunity we have a million players
it's a big number but it can triple
quadruple there's no limit and victory
for the South African team representing
Africa can help attract our youth
towards this ideal of being the best in
the world
blocking the way in Yokohama will be a
formidable England team whose own
diversity has also been an advantage
players of Nigerian and Pacific island
heritage among others making a
traditional rug
powerhouse even stronger England's
performances so far make them favorites
to repeat their World Cup triumph of
2003 and avenge their defeat to the
Springboks in the final four years later
but with South Africa is straddling both
a traditional rugby territory and the
potentially huge new on victory for them
here could mean lifting a continent as
well as a cup polarise al Jazeera
Yokohama